nursing-homes have borne the brunt of
the corona virus pandemic in this
country and some of the saddest scenes
have been of seniors passing away with
their families unable to be alongside
them joining us now mark Parkinson the
head of the nation's largest
associations of nursing homes and
long-term care facilities mr. Parkinson
a New York Times study found that
one-third more than a third of all the
deaths in this country from COBIT 19
have been in nursing homes and long-term
care facilities obviously the elderly
are an especially vulnerable population
incidentally this wasn't just patients
this was also some of the workers at
that nursing homes but why beyond that
vulnerability why do you think such a
high percentage of all the deaths have
been in these facilities well of course
you're right this has been a horrible
tragedy and for those of us that take
care of older people our entire life
it's been almost unspeakable what we've
learned from looking around the world is
that any place where people live closely
together whether it's convents or
dormitories or cruise ships or nursing
homes they're particularly vulnerable
and it's because of one very unique
feature to this virus and that is that
this virus unlike any other that we
fought before a person can catch it show
no symptoms and yet still spread it so
in January February and March when we
didn't know that we had visitors coming
into our buildings we had staff members
in our buildings closely interacting
with residents as they need to to take
care of them and we were unwittingly
spreading the virus within the
communities once the academic community
and doctors figured out that you could
be asymptomatic and care yet it was too
late for a lot of people and
unfortunately even then we didn't have
the test to figure out who had it the
good news that I can give this morning
so we're now and recovered there Chris I
just want to point out that the Trump
administration just on Friday allocated
five billion dollars secretary Hayes our
deputy secretary Hagen that's going to
allow us to recover and really make this
better
I want to point out another issue
however the Government Accountability
Office issued a report this week and I
want to put the numbers up on the screen
it found that 82% of nursing homes over
13,000 have been cited for infection
control issues from 2013 to 2017 so the
question mr. Parkinson didn't your
facilities have a problem in this
particular area long before the pandemic
hit well we have a real flawed survey
system and one of the flaws of the
survey system is that surveyors are
encouraged to give deficiencies and what
that does is it creates the impression
that even very good buildings are not
good it makes it hard for consumers to
figure out what buildings are good and
which aren't
when everybody gets deficiencies that
same GAO report reported that 99% of
those deficiencies were not severe they
did not affect patient safety and many
of them were just paperwork issues the
reality is that the coronavirus violates
all of the normal concepts of infection
control because normal infection control
is symptom related now that we know that
we are adjusting our behavior and that
is why we're starting to see recovery
and people actually getting better
visitors are no longer allowed to come
into buildings every interaction
patients and staff now have masks on
patients residents are not eating
together in the same room they're eating
privately in their own rooms so that now
that we understand the very vicious
nature of this virus were able to
control it much better nursing homes in
New York and New Jersey have been
especially hard hit by the pandemic as
well as the entire States and in late
March Governor Cuomo issued an order
that nursing homes must accept kovat 19
patients to try to alleviate and prevent
overcrowding at hospitals here's how the
governor described it and explained it
this week the CDC guidance said a
nursing home cannot discriminate against
the Kovach patient because at that time
the issue was
hospital capacity right remember
hospital capacity and we were
dramatically increasing hospital
capacity did
Governor Cuomo have to follow that CDC
guidance or did he have a choice and
what about other governor's and how they
handled the CDC guidance around the
country well look I've been a governor
in the time of a crisis so I understand
that sometimes you have to make
decisions based on incomplete
information at that time that Governor
Cuomo made that decision he was being
told by the epidemiologist at his
hospitals were going to be overrun with
Kovac patients in hindsight we now
though that was not the case there was
actually could the capacity there they
didn't need to be discharged to nursing
homes in hindsight it was an error into
Governor Cuomo's credit he has now
reversed that policy fortunately we were
able to convince most of the other
governor's across the country to not
institute that policy and I think that's
part of the reason that we're starting
to see recovery but in fact he did have
a choice he didn't have to follow the
CDC guide in this anyway
yeah I mean in hindsight you know our
suggestion to him at the time was that
he don't didn't do that I think in
hindsight he would say that it was it
was a an error it was an error again
based upon incomplete and inaccurate
information the country was too
concerned with hospitals being overrun
and there were consequences to that one
of the consequences is that nursing
homes were left out our residents were
not a high priority for testing we
weren't given the equipment that we
needed you know there needs to be some
accountability for all of these people
that were making these fantastic
estimates that the entire hospital
system across the country was going to
be overrun it wasn't and there are
consequences and unfortunately nursing
home residents were one of the
consequences I want to pick up on the
first point you made which is that we
didn't know at the very beginning a lot
of the particularly terrifying and
dangerous aspects of the corona virus
and one of them is that people could be
asymptomatic and and go into a hospital
without any sign they're ill and then
still spread the virus to these very
sick people the result as you've locked
down is
seen these terrible scenes where for
their own good
residents are kept away from their
families and some of them get very sick
some of them pass away and their
families can't be with them when that
happens what are your thoughts about
reopening nursing homes letting families
be with the residents and under what
structures under what restrictions so
that the families can be together but
you're not endangering the lives of all
the patients inside these facilities
yeah we realize how hard it's been for
family members and for residents to not
be able to be getting together and you
know we've tried to offer FaceTime and
all sorts of other alternatives but
there's just no alternative to being
together and then the tragic scenes of
people dying without their loved ones
it's just it's horrible the most
important thing is that we need to keep
koba down in the communities that the
nursing homes are in if you're a nursing
home it's in a community that has very
little COBIT there's not that huge risk
of it getting into the buildings if we
spike back up in COBIT cases though
we're gonna end up with more COBIT and
nursing homes so issue one is let's keep
Coppa down in the communities issue two
is let's get adequate testing so that we
can get a test of every staff member
every resident and then ideally if we
could get on-site testing throughout the
summer so that when people come in they
get a test we know that they're Kovan
free that would be the ideal but we do
recognize it's extremely important to
get these folks back with their families
mr. Parkinson thank you thanks for
taking time out to talk with us this
weekend and good luck in your efforts to
reopen these nursing homes sir